la parole est à monsieur lionel tardy
monsieur 2010 l'économie la loi qui
porte votre nom la loi macron devait
être la loi du siècle remède miracle
contre le chômage et pour la croissance
or mise à part la libération du
transport par autocar le bilan est bien
maigre
un chômage qui ne cesse d'augmenter une
prévision de croissance encore revu à la
baisse il ya quinze jours par le fmi
mieux six mois après la promulgation de
votre loi
seulement un tiers des 84 décret
d'application a été publié
un comble pour une loi qui était selon
vous urgente
à tel point qu'il fallait utiliser le
49-3 pour mettre fin au débat
et quand ils sont parus ou sur le point
de l'être
ces décrets sont d'une complexité
ahurissante
j'en veux pour preuve l'avant projet
relatif aux tarifs de certains
professionnels du droit
lot de 36 pages sans compter les annexes
certains extraits sont d'une complexité
inégal et que les gouvernements cubain
et nord-coréen nous envient le
paragraphe iii prévoit je cite une
évaluation de la rémunération
raisonnables basées sur un chiffre
d'affaires prévisionnel
trois formules mathématiques sont même
prévus pour calculer cette rémunération
raisonnable appelé air étoiles je cite
air et toiletter gala alpha fois tu es
petit tu fois c'est à étoile petit air
ou alors air et toiletter gaal fois fois
tes petits eu x j'ouvre les parenthèses
c'est plus serré toile fermer les
parenthèses ou enfin air étoiles est
égal à ouvrer les parenthèses al fath et
petit fois c'est fermé les parenthèses /
ouvrez les parenthèses 1 - alpha fois tu
es petit tu fermes et les parenthèses
tout cela n'est malheureusement pas une
blague monsieur le ministre
des décrets d'application qui tarde et
qui viennent complexifier la vie des
entreprises
voilà le résultat de votre loi au lieu
de s'acharner sur une réforme
constitutionnelle symbolique quand le
gouvernement va-t-il enfin réaliser que
l'état d'urgence est avant tout
économique
la parole est à monsieur emmanuel macron
mini économie de l'industrie et du
numérique
monsieur le député pour avoir longuement
et parfois notamment contribué à ce
texte
vous savez qu'il vaut mieux que ce que
vous en dites je n'ai jamais prétendu
qu'un texte de loi
et ça vaut pour le passé ça vaudra pour
le futur puisse changer la situation de
l'économie
ils y contribuent mais c'est une
mobilisation collective et elle dépasse
largement un texte
ensuite pour ce texte si vous
m'autorisez apporter les réponses
précises à des questions précises
c'est la vérité ce texte était à 60%
d'application immédiate
et pas besoin de décret pour 60% des
dispositions pour 40% des dispositions
qui n'était pas d'application immédiate
je vous confirme que à l'issue des six
mois qui suivent la promulgation de ce
texte
80% des décrets seront sortis par les
ministères et vous verrez et j'ai été à
deux reprises
auditionné par la mission de suivi qui
est présidé par le député richard
ferrand
j'ai apporté toutes les explications
nous avons comme sommes engagés transmis
tous les documents au même moment que
nous les transmettions au conseil d'état
à cette mission et je ferai un nouveau
point d'étape avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires qui avaient été impliqués
dans les deux commissions spéciales à
l'assemblée et au sénat fin février
début mars comme je l'avais fait en fin
d'année dernière
qu'on me cite beaucoup d'exercices
législatif qui ont fait preuve d'une
même transparence et d'un même suivi
surtout qu'ils ont le même nombre de
décret qui ont pu être pris aussi
rapidement aussi rapidement ensuite vous
évoquez un cas particulier qui est
d'importance celui en effet des offices
notariaux et de la tarification
mais ce qui compte ce sont les arrêtés
qui seront pré derrière puisque
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on ne vit que
sous ce régime
simplement ce sont les arrêtés qui
seront pris qui donneront les tarifs
qui aujourd'hui existe et il y en a six
ans ça n'est pas cette loi qui les a
créés simplement elle a rendu objectif
le mécanisme tarifaire qui jusqu'àlors
était beaucoup plus arbitraire et avait
conduit à des dysfonctionnements en
particulier pour des tarifs
proportionnelle qui s'était envolé avec
le marché immobilier
on peut toujours trouver des textes qui
en effet donne le sentiment de la
complexité et c'est là